ich wies sie ab
sechseinhalb stunden später eine
hatte am 8 so wie geht das juli gib mir
sind schön
verschließen
ewigkeit später drei tage später
paket das mache ich zum schluss reddy
hallo herzlich willkommen in sallys welt
dass
ich jetzt etwas mehl auf eine
jetzt ungefüllte zubereiten wollte dann
bisschen davon und winter teig so die
gleichzeitig in die pfanne geben
ich leg dich rein okay du darfst niemals
arbeitsfläche und den wunderschönen teig
das kind
das fest nicht zu heiß werden lassen so
natürlich
gefüllten nehme ich hier einfach so ein
drück dir am besten diese teig welchen
dann komm mal her
sonst kühlt es fällt zusammen wow sie
konsistenz des mädchens hat dann ist er
macht gar nichts dran machen du kannst
heute gibt es ein traditionelles
bisschen öl auf die arbeitsfläche und
ja sehr kurz aus und haben ja das bonbon
erlag kriegst du eigentlich auch was zu
flach und nehmen dann den löffel oder
nie nie niemals was den heißes fett
der käse verschlossen ist weil wenn da
guck mal hier sind die teile und wartet
und
türkisches rezept und zwar gibt es heute
ungefähr 170 grad ober unterhitze nicht
fertig wirst du wartest immer und
rollt dann den teig aus zu einem kreis
es auch einfach formen
ein paket mathe lass mich noch gucken ob
zum beispiel ein opfer war also ein
jetzt eine weiche konsistenz ist aber
essen wenn die kameras aus sind oder
ja ungefähr 60 k
nicht verschlossen ist dann so läuft es
legen okay gut das macht immer wenn du
pc und zwar wird es in der türkei gerne
ihr könnt ja auch ganz einfach vegan zu
holzstab und päpsten loch in die mitte
kriegst du nur vor der kamera essen
deswegen haben die ganzen frauen ich
1 ist hier
nicht so klebrig und den lasse ich jetzt
nicht zu dünn einfach nur so ein
ob ich mir grad raus ich habe mich
guck mal ich habe das so gemacht
heute.de
aus
bereiten indem ihr die milch einfach
auch mal zum frühstück gemacht zum
das hier ist mein thema geld nicht hatte
bisschen öffnen
und öffnete so leicht dann sind sie
sage jetzt bewusst frauen weil es haben
verbrannt aber ich nicht schlimm ich
erwachsen bist aber so macht es immer
hier abgedeckt einfach eine stunde ruhen
austausch durch pflanzliche milch
mittagessen zum abendessen eigentlich zu
geht auch mit den händen meine mama
keine männer in der türkei gekocht außer
warum ich jetzt schöner teig kugeln dass
so
habe ohnehin will
ein erwachsener okay ich mich ganz
ein postpaket aber vorsicht das ist
jeder gelegenheit wo man das eben essen
ich habe tatsächlich gerade in das heiße
nämlich schneller war wie so ein donau
oder mit hitze einfach etwa eine
gefährlich wenn da was sprit
drückt die immer einfach flach
das schützt 1 rein ja das geflecht aus
und die füllung die könnte er dann auch
köche haben die haltern immer alles per
und was sagen deine leiblichen eltern
kann es ist so ähnlich wie die
bestimmt heiß
geschlagen
fett gelangt
dreiviertelstunde halbe stunde bis 35
hand zubereitet und konnten dann eben
mit veganem schafskäse zum beispiel
dazu
dass mein haus
ungarischen langusch nämlich frittierter
als ich riet ihr jetzt noch kurz fertig
ich wollte immer gerne so auf der
und dann könnt ihr gerne wenn ihr schon
stunden bis es sich sichtbar verdoppelt
konfrontiert
mit der hand die konsistenz eben auch
dann am besten mit einem eis
machen oder einfach ohne füllung oder
teig ich weiß momentan ist das öl bis
ein paar zubereitet habt schon mal eine
arbeitsfläche und
und dann würde ich sagen darf die ella
vielleicht liegt das mit einer
eine gemüse füllung wenn ihr möchtet und
hat
portionierer ungefähr mittlerer größe
fühlen aber dadurch dass jetzt alles
probieren oder
ein knapp deswegen haushalt ist gut mit
schaumkelle reinkommen ja
das sind so schön wenn ihr die fische
pfanne erhitzen mit etwas öl oder ihr
wie das von
mich hat man jemand fragt ob er wirklich
oder je nachdem wie viel käse ihr haben
eurem öl ihr könnt aber auch das ganze
jetzt teilt ihr da kleine portionen 1
perfekt ab gemessen wird finde ich viel
könnt ihr könnt sie auch gerne im ofen
ich probier mal so 1 1 geführt
ein bonbon paket
meine kinder seid dann habe ich gesagt
in der heißluft friteuse oder im
wollt ein bisschen käse füllung eingeben
die user fragt schon ja weil die sich
einfacher mit der küchenmaschine zu
der teig ist gut aufgegangen und ich
backen dann sind aber bisher trockener
backofen zubereiten
arbeiten und ich glaube mir da
ja natürlich
und länglich verteilen
frittiert ist es natürlich immer besser
das zeige ich euch später ich habe jetzt
bei uns sicherheitsbeauftragte und immer
mittlerweile auch dann gibt es hält es
werde ein paar davon nicht füllen und
am besten noch immer zuerst die
wenn es natürlich in fett frittiert wird
und dann mit sauberen händen schön
einmal die klassische version macht muss
wenn hier was passiert kommt sie mit
einige davon aber auch 5 dafür verwende
schnittfläche legen dann verschließt die
sich auch beim einfachen zumindest
dem gedacht ihr seid so schön ihr seid
view
aber wenn bei euch auch geraten auch
schön luft geschockt so schränkt die bag
auch sagen die seen bei jedem anders aus
und sie sagt sally bitten um etwas
andere rezepte aber sonst macht es auch
ölknappheit herrscht dann könnt ihr zum
verschließen und zwar so dass wirklich
sich nämlich gleich habe ich natürlich
ich einen hirten käse ihr könnt auch ein
bei meiner mama hat die man öffnet die
bestimmt gecastet
augenmaß mama ist immer so augenmaß naja
na ja
auch kein käse ausläuft denn ansonsten
schafskäse verwenden ich nehme immer
mit der hand und macht dann so kleine
mehr lachen bogen paket nicht beachtet
beispiel ich will später mal probieren
hallo so kann ich hier am mittag
also ich frittierte jetzt hier von
ich hab dann käserei mit dem
fladen die wirklich aussehen wie
ausgesucht wie bei schauspielern
gerne diesen 60 prozentigen von gazit es
in seiner heißluft fritteuse ansonsten
ich habe jetzt die hefe den zucker und
damit da kein käse austritt und jetzt
spritzt es später im fett und das ist
langosch dann macht sie aber auch diese
gleichstellung geht es auch vor dass die
schön weit weg von der pfanne damit
ist tatsächlich unser absoluter
beiden seiten bis sie schön gold frauen
einfach mit wenig fett ausbacken
gefüllten mit käse gefüllten teile die
das wasser schon hier rein gegeben und
dann nicht so gut also wirklich gut
lieblings käse damit mache ich zum
sind nicht so dunkel werden lassen und
nichts spritzt bei explodiert
stadtkyller also hackfleisch das ist
okay ich verstand ein kindertraum wir
verschließen daher nehme ich jetzt ja
dann schütte ich erst mal das mehl drauf
beispiel auch am wochenende gerne
sind der ober kracher und ich esse am
ich probiere ich noch ein paar in der
dann reicht jetzt ein paar ungefüllte
auch kein mehl zum ausrollen sondern
doch wahnsinn ist es wie sagte sie
unseren käse tipp fürs frühstück davon
heißluft drittel nie zu viele
fett damit eben das mehl dieses anheften
gehen essen schatz
liebsten mit nutella oder mit ihren käse
und dann noch ein paar gefüllte bei den
gemacht das wäre wahnsinn gewesen aber
so ein rädchen und ein päckchen sahne
kenne ja auch so
nicht verhindert
aufkochen zwei esslöffel mehl rein
also mit diesem weichkäse oder mit
ja und dann könnte das eigentlich form
fertig perfekt und das ist so der
wie ihr wollt ich mache daher zu kleine
marmelade oder mit pit metz also mit
und salz dazu
wurde wahrscheinlich die kalorien zählen
wieso kleine schiffchen draußen
perfekte job oder brotaufstrich ist
und dann knete die den teig etwa zehn
sesam und trauten zero oder mit honig
aber was erwarte ich wohne
richtig gut und da habe ich das rezept
und so lange erhitzt schon mal hier auf
auch schon online und hier nehme ich
minuten lang geschmeidig der sollte
und kaymak mit dem rahmen also das ist
jetzt etwas vom käse und petersilie
nicht so fest sein also falls ein
der in der pfanne auf dem herd
bisschen zu festes gern noch ein
ich habe tatsächlich noch welche in der
für uns wirklich war es wenn ich in der
und da könnte jetzt einfach die
bisschen wasser dazugeben aber die menge
und dann bin ich gleich soweit und kann
türkei im urlaub bin muss ich sagen und
heißluft fritteuse zubereitet probieren
petersilie fein hacken und den käse
an wasser und milch passt genau für
wir gehen irgendwie auswärts essen ins
alles frittieren bereits zum frittieren
ja wirklich logisch ja also klar die
weizenmehl falls ihr dinkel verwendet
restaurant das bestätigt so jedem
einfach zerreiben in den händen da nehme
frühstück dazu denn zu hause mache ich
630 gebt einfach nur zwei drei esslöffel
sind dann hat mich rundum gebräunt aber
meerwasser dazu und ich mache das nicht
das tatsächlich nicht dass ich viel
was
so dass ich hier auf stufe 2 stelle dann
friedrich frites hier eher sogar nicht
wir gucken jetzt mal ob sie schon durch
aber meine mama gemacht schocken und
auch schon die temperatur einstellen auf
sind die waren jetzt 16 minuten drin
dann gehen wir zum besten ja ich zeige
etwa 34 grad dann wird der teig nämlich
euch heute jetzt beide versionen und
schon mal weich und warm und geht später
zeige ich jetzt aber erst mal wie man
den hefeteig zubereitet
hammer
schneller auf perfekt und der teig hat
dafür verwende ich einen halben würfel
hefe einen esslöffel zucker
er macht so besser oder man muss ehrlich
375 gramm wasser 350 gramm milch einen
beide und gelangt immer diplomatisch
esslöffel salz und ein kilo mehl das
als ich muss sagen die sehen auch so aus
nimmt ihr die hefe und zerbröselt sie in
damit sind die heißluft fritteuse 45
eine rührschüssel meine mama die kette
den teig emma per hand aber ich habe ja
stück reingebracht wenn diese optisch
jetzt auch letztes jahr dort nämlich
jetzt nicht so schön aber ich denke die
schon 23 jahre her die zeit die vergeht
hätten noch ein bisschen sie können noch
drei minuten dann sind sie auch schön
so schnell habe ich ja auch eine kenwood
aber so finde ich super nicht mal
gegeben damit sie eben auch schön backen
probieren ja von wem er ist viel zu heiß
und es immer noch zu heiß da habe ich
kann und nicht mehr so viel kneten muss
und dann dadurch packt jetzt noch mehr
denke das paket probieren
aber sie sagt trotzdem immer sie ist es
ich weiß einmal ab ja
halt immer gewohnt gewesen so mit der
aber ich nehme so ein kleines stück das
hand die teige zu verkneten und da merkt
ich muss ehrlich sagen ich war
man die konsistenz und alles aber ich
voreingenommenheit gesagt niemals so gut
muss auch sagen dass er früher die
aber in der
türkischen rezepte oder auch bis heute
friteuse schmeckt es schmeckt anders
noch die hatten keine gramm anzahl an
irgendwie dann überließ außen ist
irgendwie kluge sprüche ich weiß
nicht
was du kannst du schreiben ja ich hatte
zwar die krise bei den roten aber jetzt
mal ganz ehrlich also ein heißluft und
ich glaube kein fett bringen gewesen
jetzt ganz wenig nur eines lafontaine
ich wollte euch egal gewesen ist schon
weg vom fenster das ding ist schon
brutal ging ja meine krieg
hätte
ich besser
also nicht schlecht nur anders also es
spielt nur anders ich kriegen anderes
macht's gut
ich habe kein auto ich hab mein bauch
ist erreicht ist der enkel flutscht
wahnsinn erst durch den anruf gespürt
okay gut also ihr findet das rezept auf
belize medius blog de oder in meiner app
schaut er gerne vorbei und falls ihr die
fische schon kennt könnt ihr mir gerne
schreiben ob ihr sie gerne gefüllt oder
ungefüllt ist und was event dazu
serviert was ist schon am liebsten mit
käse oder ohne
also wir lassen es uns schmecken euch
auch einen guten appetit und noch einen
schönen ramadan bis dann
das nehmen jetzt gleich so ein ganz
[Musik]